was für eine woche meine damen und
herren ich weiß ich sagte dass jede
woche aber diesmal stimmt was für eine
woche ich prophet habe an dieser stelle
schon im oktober gesagt zur not muss
thüringen dieses große waldgebiet
kommissarisch von einem förster regiert
werden
und jetzt ist es noch schlimmer gekommen
ja mit thomas kemmerich wird ein
fdp-mann ministerpräsident für mehrere
stunden ja und zwar mit hilfe der afd
jeder historische moment wo ihm
gratuliert ausgerechnet hatte
ausgerechnet meine damen und herren
dessen flügel völlig zu recht vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird seit
diesem handshake hier kommt die afg aus
dem feiern gar nicht mehr raus wirklich
die drehen durch so gesehen wirklich ein
deprimierender mittwoch tatsächlich gab
ist wenn ich darüber nachdenke nur einen
moment der mich zumindest ein bisschen
aufgeheitert wir hatten einen fornas
wahlziel
wir wollten rot rot grün beenden wir
wollten bodo ramelow den verdienten
politischen ruhestand schicken
[Applaus]
so aber selbst das war kein richtiger
trost in dieser woche ja selbst das
nicht wirklich eine zäsur was da
passiert ist kemmerich und der thüringer
cdu chefs mike mohring oder wie ich sie
nenne helfer die beiden fallen wirklich
auf diesen unfassbar billigen afd
bauerntrick rein warum ernsthaft wenn
überhaupt stirbt unsere demokratie nicht
an der afd sondern eine doofe der
anderen parteien
der däne tanken das hat mich echt
deprimiert der dilettanten stadl von
erfurt ein absoluter hier wie sagt man
dass nach wir erwarten einen dammbruch
was die reaktionen angeht das ist ein
absoluter dammbruch ein politischer
dammbruch dieser dammbruch dammbruch
dammbruch dammbruch dammbruch dammbruch
dammbruch beine nicht
[Musik]
dammbruch dann noch das wort da muss man
sehr oft
damen das schlimmste wort der deutschen
sprache nach dem schnitt natürlich die
rassisten von der afg als königsmacher
wenn auch nur für eine nacht schlimm
genug und es bleiben so viele rätsel so
viele fragen stellen sie sich doch
wahrscheinlich auch was zum teufel war
der plan was hat sich die fdp bietet
dabei gedacht diesen kemmerich überhaupt
ins rennen zu schicken
das ist immer so bei den bei den
beobachtern danach stunden später ist
man viel schlauer und weiß was man tun
muss
herr kemmerich war offensichtlich
übermannt
hinterrücks übermannt der arme kerl
unschuldig ins ministerpräsidentenamt
gezwungen und dann hat er sich auch noch
aus versehen vereidigen lassen so eine
pechsträhne aber auch würden hatte
jeweils einer so viel pech es ist es ist
eine hochnotpeinliche nummer auch für
lindner persönlich deswegen hat er ja
heute im fdp parteivorstand die
vertrauensfrage gestellt
natürlich in der sicheren gewissheit was
ihnen die anderen liberalen
pappkameraden sowieso nicht abwählen
hier berühmter fdp wahlspot von uns
sagen wir mal aktualisiert
haben sie mal was gemacht von dem sie
überzeugt waren dass es richtig ist
da schickt dir niemand eine sms und sagt
das war richtig das hast du gut gemacht
[Musik]
explodieren die kommentare
jetzt drehen sie durch idioten ganz
falscher weg wer soll das wählen
du hast das alles vorher gewusst und
trotzdem gemacht
ja es ist schon im ausland
man sollte die politik wirklich den
profis überlassen
selbst wenn man aus versehen
ministerpräsident wird wieso nimmt man
die wahl an
was ist denn da los in thüringen
eigentlich so ein tolles bundesland ganz
ehrlich mit sehr vielen meine ich
ehrlich klugen sympathischen menschen
was da passiert ist war schon demokratie
also parlamentarische demokratie nur
halt in sehr dilettantische ausführung
und deswegen hat mainz zdf nach seiner
thüringen sondersendung wohl extra das
programm geändert
das war unser zdf spezial vielen dank
für ihr interesse hier geht's gleich
weiter mit der krimiserie blutige
anfänger
das ist mal
vorausschauende programmplanung und
natürlich war thüring auch ein debakel
für annegret kramp karrenbauer
ja natürlich absolutes debakel ja
spätestens seit mittwoch muss ihr klar
sein dass wachsende teile ihrer cdu
immer mehr nach rechts blinken
das betrifft die ost verbände aber
natürlich auch die sogenannte werte
union für die sind nämlich in erster
linie die linken der gegner und nazis
offenbar das geringere übel
wohlgemerkt im jahr eins nach halle und
der ermordung von walter lübke ernsthaft
wie viel autorität hat kaká noch das
verhalten der cdu in thüringen im
dritten wahlgang geschah ausdrücklich
gegen die empfehlungen und gegen die
forderungen und bitten der bundes partei
das will ich noch einmal ganz klar
stellen
ich habe das gesagt dass ich mir das
ganz toll wünsche und dann haben alle
gelacht am telefon und haben einfach
aufgelegt
das kann ich nicht okay ehrlich das geht
doch so nicht weiter nach unserer
informationen gibt es nur noch einen in
der union nur noch einen der sich von a
kk führen lässt und zwar ist dass dieser
kollege hier
und selbst der tritt glaube ich bald in
die werte union ein ja hätte hkk die cdu
thüringen auch lieber mal rechtzeitig
kassiert jetzt ist das chaos perfekt
jetzt ist das chaos perfekt die fdp will
neuwahlen die cdu plötzlich doch nicht
mehr weil ihnen eingefallen ist dass man
bei einer neuen war noch schlechter
abschneiden könnte ja realistische
einschätzung und eine weitere folge aus
der serie wir basteln uns noch mehr
politikverdrossenheit echt bitter
dietmar wischmeyer über den historischen
mittwoch von erfurt
the history mit dietmar wischmeyer
sowas braucht man eigentlich für eine an
feste staatskrise militär das die
rundfunkstationen besetzt panzer auf den
straßen schlüssel in der nacht kann sein
manchmal reichen aber auch schon zwei
doofe mike mohring und thomas kemmerich
jeder und wenn ich sage jeder dann meine
ich sogar ak hatte kommen sehen was die
afb da plant aber wie genau ist denn der
mehrfach orientierungslose cdu-mann
mohring auf seine idioten strategie
gekommen
nach meinen informationen wahrscheinlich
während einer taz podiumsdiskussion hier
kaum geschnittenes material
ich will noch mal diese vielleicht
libertärer konsens aber wir heben über
windenergie und partizipation und wir
diskutieren jetzt schon wieder über ein
spärlich präzisieren
aber das rechnet sich einfach noch nicht
und da muss der bund was in dieser in
diesen hitzigen tagen etwas was man bei
spiegel online ich glaube auch bei uns
ist das nicht schade ganz kurz 100
anlagen also die demoskopie der warte ja
haben wir uns bleibt etwas spannenden
kulturring ein wir brauchen wir noch für
herrn mohring
wenn wir da auch als thüringer politik
ist lüfter mit vertragen und das hier
bauen und exakt der moment in dem die
beiden möchtegern macht übernehmer ihren
wasserdichten plan ausbaldowern
kemmerich so passau mit mike im dritten
wahlgang komme ich aus der hecke
geilomat meister proper genau so machen
wir es
und der rest ist nach 24 stunden und 34
minuten schon wieder geschichte
trotzdem hat bernd hocke seit mittwoch
ein dauer ständer
wenigstens muss man sich aber um thomas
kemmerich keine sorgen machen der kann
jetzt wieder zurück in seinen alten job
deine cowboystiefel hatte als marke
etabliert genauso wie die glatze die er
selbst pflegt wie er sagt obwohl ihm
eine friseur kette gehört ja das passt
doch seine läden heißen übrigens haare
dolf und machtergreifung
immerhin sehen wir das positive stärker
wirtschaftlich verteidigungsminister von
thüringen und die ard darf erfurt nicht
in landeshauptstadt germania umbenennen
läuft und in der nächsten folge von
heute show history unternehmen unterhose
wie die afg jetzt ungeniert das braune
nach außen kehrt marsch geigensolo war
doch versprochen ihr könnt ja in der
zeit den kanal abonnieren
[Musik]